Альмерія. Південь Іспанії.
Це найбільша теплиця у світі.
Її працівники скаржаться на умови роботи,
наближені, за їхніми словами, до сучасного рабства.
Без наркотиків ми тут не можемо жити.
Ми вживаємо наркотики, щоб думати про щось інше.
Наприклад, про наші родини у майбутньому, про яке ми мріяли,
але якого ніколи не матимемо.
Більшість із 90-та тисяч працівників - мігранти з Африки,
які подолали довгий шлях морем, щоб опинитися тут.
Для фермерів вони - дешева робоча сила.
А для них самих ця робота -
надія на краще майбутнє, яка, правда, гасне з кожним днем.
Люди, які приїжджають з Африки та інших країн,
залишаються на півдні Іспанії,
адже тут вони можуть знайти роботу без офіційного дозволу.
Так, це нелегально,
але це єдиний спосіб вижити для них.
Робота цих людей ніде офіційно не зафіксована.
Жодних контрактів і жодної оплати за понаднормову працю.
Люди мешкають неподалік ферми
у власноруч зведених з аби-чого наметах.
В них практично немає доступу до питної води і струму.
Мої роботодавці - це кримінальні організації,
кі можуть собі дозволити витрачати мільйони
на будівництво теплиць, але не можуть звести житло
для власних співробітників.
Цей фермер каже, що справедливо оплачує роботу своїх працівників.
Утім зізнається: не всі його колеги роблять так само.
Мінімальна зарплата за законом має бути не меншою за 46 євро на день.
Але працівники переважно отримують до 35-ти євро
за день роботи при тепличній температурі 50 градусів.
Та фермери змагаються з Марокко та Туреччиною за здешевлення виробництва.
Адже великі мережі європейських супермаркетів весь час тиснуть ціни донизу.
Ми пережили кризу, під час якої ми мусили продавати огірки
за менш ніж 20 центів. Ціна впала до 8 центів за кілограм.
Як нам в таких умовах покривати виробничі витрати? Неможливо.
Я думаю, що саме тому багато ферм так погано поводяться з працівниками.
Поодинокі мітингувальники відстоюють права більшості працівників,
які щороку збирають тут три з половиною мільйони тонн овочів та фруктів.
Робота - так! Але з правами!
У нас є рішення - корупціонерів у в'язницю!
Ми помираємо за людей на Півночі,
які їдять помідори звідси.
Та більшість нелегальних працівників боїться втратити
свою, як вони кажуть -"рабську" - роботу.
Тому мовчать - і збирають помідори для європейських покупців.